だしておっしゃですか
髪型さえしっかりしてればなぁ
[音楽]
rar
ああああああ
やりますがおにぎりを病んでいきたいとおもいます
院長主ブラジはずが決まってるんで
ウイルス対策が2ですね
プロジェクトだノーマルはいお願いしまーす re ずっころもついていただいて
注意していただきたいと思います私はいつものよいいねはいお願いします入ってこの中
からピックアップして
はいお願いします20個ずつ20個で1回お願いします
子供だぞ多分本部と接しまあ気がしてるんじゃないですか
[音楽]
いるおりましたあああ
福じゃあ
じゃあまたほっ
よし
バッハ
voodoo
[音楽]
配当や外でボケ何をしているかといいますと
は今その
コロナウィルスとかでちょっと
ね色々大変な
世の中でして
鉄鋼
学校に行けない子供たちとか
保育所とかもですよね保育園とか何かそういう子どもたちが
普段
お父さんお母さんとかが仕事に行って
預けられるべき場所にいけない子たちがたくさんいてそれでもお父さんお母さん働きに
行かなきゃなんてご飯のず日ができないとか言う
子どもたちのすごい多いらしくてですね
そこでローソンさんの取り組みで路そのおにぎりを無双で
フォアの準備できない子どもたちに嘘で配っているっていう
取り組みをされているというのを聞いて
こんな今なんです
僕らも何かできることはないかなと思ってちょっと o
おにぎりを配りに行っているところでございます
すごい親からすると助かるものだと思うんだよ
給食とかねその幼稚園とか
家にいてもねぇ
辛いする
ん
ます
一番入ってる方だ言葉ですね
ていましたただん
火造さん
と思いまーす
1わー
ああああああ
はあああああああああ
あっん
も逃げ持ってきたよ
もうちょっと大丈夫大丈夫かパンかこんにちわまっちゃ
にゃんって言ってる
それを言ってくれねー
どうぞさんに応募しました私はチャラ
正三さんが学童さんもたちが猫が困ってるからとして届き肉要請でなくありました
これみんなにガス代のを握るのを中継やけ初級
上を据え tt
手術になるよ
政治家ますけど
teen 1俺は4月がいますよね
ん何よゲスト
おっなんか見てることがある
みんなをより速い3食べるぞただは
強うん
[音楽]
品川に一部が言うと上の子が家が10駅
簡単だけどめでとうござい
俺予約していません
て朝からクーラー
nd nd
10枚で好きな人から
颯爽と走る
[音楽]
ん
俺のどうぞ俺がもしああ
ねっタブ分け最初から待ってなければたぶん
nani
ran
竹芸
ああああああ
飾り波
[拍手]
too
fanic
ポイント2倍
はーい
pou dou dou
ございましたん
めちゃくちゃそんなだけにませんただああーーー
狼爪さんのご協力もあっておにぎりを渡してきたわけなんですけども
そうですね
こんな世の中あっ
この技術の影響で本当にいまー
にできることが何もできない中共が日本だけじゃなくて
社会的に起きているという
思いますあそぼと思いますねずみだって学校自体がないかもしれないんですけどそう
じゃなくても
今年そういう影響でねー
卒業していたか出れなかった学生の人とかたくさんいたと思うんですけど
芭蕉すると何していいかわかんないですね
イベントとかも全部だめだしできることがあまりなくて
やっちゃダメということは非常に多くてマスクとかはないとか本当に入っ
世界とき
すごい族だと思って
僕は動画とるのがすることで撮らせていただいているんですけども何か他議員
できないからって思った時に託児所に扱っている子どもたちにも倫理で受かるとかそう
ことができるんだなと思って手伝わせていただきました
はい特に今動画で皆さんに何かしてくれとか
何か良い子しようとかいたいわけじゃなくて
なんか
できることが本当不戦勝でふざけしていいかわかんなくて
動画とリヴァイ僕にできるのはあっ
そういうことだったのかなって言う
今できることを一つとしてやらせていただきました
これをきっかけに
なにか出来る人が目立っていいなと思ってます本当にはちょっと日本が活気運営
ないん
活気がでんねまあないのは2人目だと思うんですけども
その中でもちょっとずつ
みんなでできることを探して
いざ約こういう状況がなればいいなと思っています
みんなで頑張りましょう
ここを引き続き動画を頑張らせていただきます
ファンの人に楽しガッタス遊ぶぞ
じゃあ
[音楽]